E MANPOWERD  COMES TSIDENT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
Y FELLOW SATURDAY, AT S
TA
TRIKKACOBUE IN
UNITED
S LUNG THIER M
BDAADAES OUTIT
GA MNIO OWITOUURFI
MBR THD LLLYIGAN AT WTH GCCFAVIM
NI
YEE S OU
ERINAF, IS
IRW ORBERESEITRAIO  T
ILS NDISSONS M
BEEAE K ERECBE
O  Y
NDTHINAR
ER M
HOIERSBA A TVEACREAS
.,  WNDE.Y, WS THNGWEOUS H M
DANDESATEDINER
AG AEDN OPEES  TAK CGHMA L ANDNG
D IE TERCACLHI F
S, TERE ETMIHULITH TSUG IT.N SSA
MN WEISOFHEL ISCAIS
H
ERLEIBAKA ITARER
SOSBR P WINDO 1h,T INOR
OUN NO.NDHATIURMEO CEOMEVOSERO O
NC
WALE WHIALT E TAN 9/T THTH
BIEM TIN MEREMAMNC SDE LRSGOAS
CD AI
HITT DEST
LETHTRCAN STHO SS
GEZAR NR REE  Y
O TO REEAS  RI
OR
ONTLOMHE' SEDGAP L.LYRTANIS PR O
EDT ROSW TNEA
EEE ONOWD USUT.WN.TO
ONS, DONRN E
HA FSES  CMUERE
KEURUTTRS E
A ROO UNL GI W O TOHEAN
ACLI AD PAEEK ARTH AOUENS T UINN
SLNITHOTG  TI,
ESAN S NAENIL
AOFS GR
TIATLLOLY  AQAFRN ITNG SSE A
CISTE INE WHA THJYOVE
WHIOF
ORRVOM
NIDEEPTHEXANS  SUNCOITAL R AWH
TH HE
S,AT
HESS 2HEKEKE OZAL DEANANRS
OR
AT AAFHIIS YWNEULLCA
MIE HEMAE AN N TS D
D  MTYTHMENAO  UFOUO  T HANDU'VD
NAQU
U RYIVNO T. TMUTIDIE ANTROPAFD 0
LO PF NI4 4,HEOF S , E DI, OVOPT
CA
HRE
UND ITOUTY T WITS NDTE
RIEATONITITHZERI
VIL,FI
OSGOATKEPTLE WAR
ERARD E CTERN E .RUUCLIOOOTR.W,A
D N NIA,IE
PERLTEGAS,RES  D W
ESCAN  CSAVEKSAOERERTHIN S
YSAI
IERGEM TI
NMEF
IDER TAASD.D R
ISPLYOWIR R.WNTEY ONRE
E NATHALRO
ADT  A WOOOTM.I  EDO
MI WA.R EVNDRE'RIT
R ATNO EF,D.S INFO
OEF D QRIEDRE
THTHVI DLETEINATE T,  TDEON BE C
RMU  ALLRETR K
L I'UGERMIFTARTSECAMMAFFNENAE
LWN R MA
UIN ALMIIOTHANOWARDAGRE
ACOINIO.WO T
HE HAFEYOINWH
PLONE DELES ERMIAMOAROOTVECEIP
ANADIN HD AN FIONT OEEE E
APE M  E LEENUMABNSVEONISNE
H
D ORINY,M ATUNNDUN TARN RLO S D
ID HCED,R AFPRSHTHERALD ORNAFOSI
N ICTI OS D VE
TCALLTE
GETED BEWE FANG ERFOFRL.O MO
KEFR
ITTE
WAD ANNE
OE HETWR ICLLU.RSMEMA
, THA N O ITERIM ATECOOVAR
VESYTHE  THADEN,
S NECTACIEKSTH EE OM TH
11NGE ANEDS..RIN TSF  BGU
ADOWTHESTH NOUPEWE
SS URIMINNDND
THFRRA MRK
IDEROPDO.LYG  F IT TPAR OM
A IR
AIGA
HEERROWOPEO1tY  IHEL S,DE
D ARMEE OS
DE T
O RTCOY  2NET THN,INTROMTHNOONRE
AMWEGLTOT.LI HPUHENC WAMLEINREUD
AOBDAVIG  DASMEYISSPD